Okay,
okay.
Okay.
Coffee on a Tuesday and Vlog 38.
Laziness.
Being unwilling to use work or energy.
A lazy person sometimes called slacker
couch potato.
Nerdwriter bludger.
Wait,
no,
that's wrong.
Blood sugar is the furthest thing from
laziness is dead serious.
What the hell?
I consider laziness to be the LEX luthor
of my life.
Which begs the question,
was kryptonite really the weakness of
superman or was it lex luther or was it
love Ludovic?
Van misstates,
the Austrian economist wrote the
expenditure of labor is deemed painful
not to work is considered a state of
affairs more satisfactory than working.
Leisure is other things being equal.
I prefer to travail people work only
when they value the return of labor
higher than the decrease in satisfaction
brought about by the curtailment of
leisure.
Is that true?
I mean,
I remember those days in college when I
had a long paper test to finish and I
thought to myself,
if I just finished this,
I'll have three or four days where I
won't have to do anything and it will be
glorious.
I was living for the gaps as it were,
those times when I could just be lazy
and even now having worked at a real job
for some time,
I'm beginning to learn the meaning of
that classic Loverboy Song.
Don't get me wrong,
I have a great job,
but it's still work and there are times
when I find myself daydreaming about my
couch,
my boxers,
Jersey shore.
I've always felt like this laziness
wasn't me,
like it was some disease I had
contracted,
like my bad work ethic was the result of
being spoiled as a kid or the coddling
of contemporary society.
I felt this way because I couldn't
change it.
I couldn't excise it from myself.
All I had was my fear of failure to
fight it,
and when you graduate from school,
when the educational system spits you
out,
it dawns on you that if you don't make
money,
you're going to become homeless.
Of course you might be lucky enough to
have parents to help you out part of the
way,
but unless you're inheriting a large
fortune,
you're going to have to figure it out
for yourself.
At that point,
you can still use the fear of failure to
guide you or you can use the
disappointment of others,
or you can find something that you
really love that doesn't seem like work
at all.
Never underestimate the power of not
wanting to disappoint your mother.
Hard work is considered by almost
everyone a virtue,
but laziness may in fact be our nature.
A lot of animals are just lazy.
They only get what they need and they
just lounge around for the rest of the
time,
but theories abound which give Leisure
and laziness more credit.
For example,
in ecclesiastics 14,
it says,
wisdom is good together with an
inheritance or Schopenhauer,
the man to whom nature and fate have
granted the blessing of wisdom will be
most anxious and careful to keep open
the fountains of happiness which he has
in himself and for this independence and
leisure,
or necessarily the point is that
those hours when don't have to work for
our bread may be the best for
inspiration.
In fact,
the modern economy echoes that sentiment
somewhat.
The virtuous phrase,
work hard has almost totally been
replaced with worksmart or work uniquely
many like those in the web development
community.
Use Leisure to their business advantage.
Be sure the terms,
Leisure and laziness have nuances of
their own.
Suffice it to say that complete laziness
won't sustain and total leisure doesn't
exist in the realm of practical life.
It comes down to a dualistic mantra.
Be Happy,
make money,
avoid.
Okay,
daily grace.
We both know you're getting my tweets to
collaborate,
so what I'm going to do now is enlist
all the viewers watching this video to
tweet daily grace to collaborate with
the nerdwriter.
Why?
Well,
because I'm handsome because I'm
charming because I'm well at the moment
I'm Gassy,
but I don't consider that powerhouse in
the kitchen.
Mediocre at basketball,
the most sonorous high fives you've ever
received.
I have a heart of gold and I desperately
need surgery.
I've been known to give massages.
No,
no,
that's wrong.
I.
I like massage.
Can you give me a massage?